hallo ich hier meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur zweiten folge
feet wird dies zusammen mit um gespielt
aber was ungespielt kurz sagen möchte
und zwar etwas für deine band ja genau
also ich habe meine ich habe die erste
aufnahme im schnitt aufgenommen weil ich
mir doch unsicher war ja passt jetzt auf
meinen kanal soweit ich bin eher so pvp
orientiert aber da ich noch nie
minecraft display gemacht habe und jetzt
eigentlich der letzten folge hat also
überzeugt bin hier von uns so richtig
begeistert ja welchen kanal auch
hochladen an alle meine zuschauer jetzt
die erste folge könnte exklusiv dann auf
konkurs des kanals warte ich hörte den
redouan von walter k die erstaufnahme
könnt ihr dann exklusiv also wie alles
begann
gibt es eine exklusive von craft das
kanal also schaut auf jeden fall die
erste folge ist ganz wichtig um mal zu
verstehen was wir genau machen
dann brauche ich doch nicht erzählen was
es hier ist und so dürft könnt ihr
einfach gucken also wir spielen hier
vize dafür kannst du noch sagen einem
lichtbild fiel zwar haben sich ein paar
dinge verändert und ihr habt eine menge
kommentare geschrieben wir uns natürlich
die erste folge erst mal angeguckt bevor
wir was er muss ich nicht angekommen ist
kommentare angeguckt bevor wir hier
weiter aufnehmen und zwar habe ich das
du mir das so gemacht du hast du glaub
ich noch nicht gemacht
zwecks upgedatet geupdatet da werde ich
dann noch helfen wenn du hilfe brauchst
wir haben nämlich viele leute von euch
in die kommentare geschrieben
hey das kannst du doch alles rund zu
updaten da gibt es doch sechs addons und
das habe ich auch gemacht und ihr seht
zum beispiel wenn ich mir jetzt mal zu
moschitz gab es hilfe blöcke die nicht
da der zum beispiel der wird nun auch
das in spex design die ganzen blumen
auch und da möchte ich mich bei euch
bedanken dass wir uns so viele uns oft
so hilfreiche kommentare geschrieben
habt und nicht über vier sie hat den weg
kennt also das kam natürlich auch aber
vize biest ist eindeutig geiler weil
wählt natürlich auch neue biome ec2
haben und nicht nur paar komische sachen
die ihnen was mit technik
ja und ich glaube ich gibt doch eine
sache bei dies hier also dieses projekt
gibt es hier nicht gibt dass ich ganz
gut finde weil rät eckert ist sowohl
eine liste irgendwann durch größe
erreicht hat ist es so als könnte man
wie im creative macht einfach rumfliegen
und alles und diese ganzen sachen machen
und staub so an balance wird das hier
nicht also wir werden immer noch im meer
werden bodenständig bleiben und hier
später rom fliegen
nein also das ist natürlich hier alles
ein bisschen ich möchte ich sagen
simpler weil es auch schon sehr
umfangreiches aquin bzw
es ist sogar vielleicht noch
umfangreicher als text selbst weil hält
viele sachen hinzugefügt wurden aber auf
jeden fall nicht solche op sachen wie
zum beispiel dann ja dass man halt mir
wie du schon mal dass rom fliegen kann
und so ich brauche erstmal sind projekt
mehr nach oben machen stimmt meist hier
reicht das heißt das wollen wir in der
wenig darauf näher darauf eingehen dann
noch eine axt
ich mag mein brot okay wir haben uns
jetzt schon mitteilen keine sachen oder
wie man es teilen also gehört mir und so
weiter ja also wenn jetzt einer ganz
viel eisen hat dass er den einander
nichts als abgibt weil wir dann
natürlich und später auch eigene häuser
bauen und so also da war ich ja also ich
würde auch sagen wir wir sind mal
komplett so gegeneinander regal privat
kölner stadt willich sachen geben aber
rasch und gary das ist sache tauschen
das heißt wenn ich auch weshalb das geil
ist dann musst du auch was geist
aufgegeben hat genau tauschen das ist
doch mal gut das ist wirklich erst
erfolgen wenn du nicht so drüber spricht
würdest was kann alles kaputt was nicht
gebaut hat ich bin trampel brot schenken
als als
als zeichen meiner entschuldigung
betreuer laufen ja ich bin darüber
gelaufen aber nur wenn man darüber
sprechen kaputt ach so gut damit ja kein
drittes eindeutig zu werden ja aber
daran sich ab mit dem dingens noch nicht
so viel plan hier also da ist auch so
ein echter nicht voll gerade sagen das
ist nicht von vize dies dass man da
rumspringt nein nein ich bin eher nur
wirklich pvp pve pvp okay also wie
ungespielt am anfang schon meinte die
ganzen folgen können die noch auf seinem
kanal angucken wer steht ja seit der
ersten folge in der beschreibung könnt
ihr euch dort einfach durchlesen
vorbeischauen und so weiter dann seht
ihr es aus seiner sicht und was ich nun
auch oben rechts drin auf ist eine
holztreppe nein natürlich nicht aber es
ist ein spotlight und zwar wenn ich zum
beispiel hier auf das gitter drauf gucke
steht auch eisengitter steht zb
pflasterstein
hier steht das gras blog ich höre hier
ist sowas von viele zombies
genau an dieser stelle wollen das nicht
sagen wie das sind einfach nur tote
für kinos weil ich immer so viel spielte
sich schon gar keine zombies der war
niemals es geht nach alter da drin sind
zombies ich ja jetzt erst mal weg hier
guck mal da gibt nochmal günter rüdiger
krüger denn der steht immer noch selber
stehen haben uns ist unsere netten
menschen vergessen der uns bei sich
wohnen lassen hat dessen creeper im haus
von dem pc warte ich versuche zu bitten
würdest du mir vielleicht ein werkzeug
tauschen ich würde dafür was schönes
geben wenn nicht werkzeuge ach ja ich
hab werkzeug nicht selber doppelt
ich habe alles nur ein wan und meist ist
holz auch da muss jetzt auf die suche
gehen in zwei total dann willst du
übrigens mit täglich hochladen wollte
mir das noch sagen ja also also die
resonanz beim beim ersten part sag ich
mal war ja eigentlich sehr sehr positiv
und sehr sehr viele kommentare sehr
konstruktive kommentare hilfreiche
kommentare zwingen haben wir uns
eigentlich mal so den anschluss gepackt
dass wir das erstmal ich werde diese
komische spotlight funktion doch ich
nehme komme ich das machen wir das erst
mal täglich hochgeladen werden und dann
schaue schon werden die es ankommt bei
euch und so weiter und um gespielt dass
auch täglich hochladen wenn wir
irgendwie dann uns mal anders
entscheiden
möglich ist dann sei aber dann sagen wir
euch natürlich noch bescheid
übrigens an meine zuschauer ist man eben
ich baue mich dorthin wo ich gerade
hingucke da ungefähr so wartet das
solltet ihr auch zeigen wollen wir jetzt
zusammen wo ich mich hin bauen dann
kannst du dich da neben ihnen die bauen
weil ich hätte mir so gedacht dass du
das bestimmt ganz gut für das wasser
siehst du mich hier links
ich wollte mir schon mal hin und her um
gespielt
ich glaube im internet das abgepackte
meinte sachs das ist das ist jetzt der
skype sound also ist natürlich jetzt
äußerst professionell was ihr welche
gerade machen dass ungespielt hakt dabei
mir verbindung bei s&t schlecht ich mach
mal im statusbericht also skype womit
ihr immer noch rumgespielt letzte game
gut ich froh das lag nicht an jeden
definitiv nicht an mir ist aufgefallen
hier sind sehr viele zombies vielleicht
habe ich einfach monster allgemein
vielleicht will ich einfach die
einstellung falsch da ist so ein
komischer grafik fragt habe ich
eigentlich schon aber schon viele hallo
du hast dein internet war weg meint
taylor weg du bist vom server geflogen
ach so hat ein interreg b also du bist
vom server geflogen so viel kann ich
sagen ach ich hab grad im erster erfolge
gesagt dass sein internet wahrscheinlich
weg ist deswegen ist aber darum gegangen
bei mir läuft es aber noch ich bin ja
drauf deswegen also was ich eigentlich
zeigen wollte
kommst du da draufsteht da für windows
server wenn er dann mal verbringen würde
jetzt sind die mozilla kaputtes wäre ich
bei einem anmelden
tatsächliche resultate goßmann aufnahme
wieder du bist irgendwo runtergefallen
sich fraglos
etwa schon
hab
auch hier sind bäume
bis dahin ist ein ganz normales bier da
freue ich mich aber ach so hast du die
aufnahme ausgemacht moment so jetzt
schafft man aufnahmen
ja ich musste hat man auch noch
abgebrochen weil ich nicht wusste wie
lange der weg ist weil er der meinung
dass das internet weg ist aber ich habe
gesagt wir sehen uns nach einer kurzen
unterbrechung
ja ich nehme das die ganze zeit einfach
somit auf das sehen die leute mal hierzu
hinter den kulissen
ja das ist auch spannend so aber du
nimmst jetzt wieder auf richtig ich bin
jetzt gerade wieder auf ihren stühlen
also als akt bei mir und dann genau
also ich warum ich hier hin
wahrscheinlich und dann dachte ich mir
dass du dich da einlässt auf die
schönberg auf die andere seite und dann
machen wir eine brücke und eine unseres
rückkehrer handel sind an was unten
lassen
über wasser brücke und unter wasser mit
glas oder sowas
wer ihren besonderen glastüren tunnel so
ich weiß wenn ich das umsetzen kann
welche eine woche nicht bauen
ja das also ich habe richtig lust zu
bauen weil ich also ich will sich selbst
irgendwie nicht gut reden und so aber
ich bin der überzeugung dass ich schon
ein wenig dauern kann und aber viel zu
selten haltbar
und deswegen zeigt euch das mal ganz gut
so wenn man rückt dann kann ich jetzt
hier einfach auf options klicken dann
mache ich hier
highlight tipps mache ich dann mache ich
wieder oh so und jetzt sind die tipps
hier weg sodass neft in den jahrmarkt
minimiert noch eben andere seite so
jetzt hammas gut dann würde ich sagen
ich transportiere meine sachen schon mal
von anna b und werde erst mal eine menge
erde brauchen also was ich vorhin auf
seinen bogen wir sind aber viele ärzte
dann hatte ich muss da einfach mal ganz
kurz und gucken
ich bin hin süchtig was ja viele uns in
die kommentare geschrieben haben kannst
du auch bestätigen viele tipps und mir
wurden auch viele nachrichten gesendet
von wegen
wir können hier tipps geben addons bei
skype es ist natürlich wieder so eine
sache
also es mag leute geben die dann den
diese personen hätten und damit ihr
darüber quatschen oder so aber ich bin
da eigentlich nicht so für dass man
leute einfach von youtube skype at weil
man sich nicht auf sie verlassen kann
sage ich mir dass ein blog der nicht für
stack speck ausgelegte sich gerade
allerdings meinen etats von community
publikum sagen
deswegen werden wir euch doch sehr
verbunden wenn ihr tipps und tricks in
die kommentare schreiben könnte dann
irgendwie ihr seht ja so ein paar mods
die hier so dabei sind also die habt ihr
schon am anfang gesehen zum beispiel
portal dann wasser soul-stars computer
kraftraum kraft so verschiedene sachen
halt und wenn ihr zu den sachen einfach
irgendwas willst dann schreibt einfach
jahr zu 1000 grad kann ich euch sagen
dass ihr sohn thomas und dies macht und
dann macht passiert das und das also das
kann ja kurz den kommentaren oder
einfach per nachricht weil das ist heldt
schon let's play together von uns beiden
und da möchten jetzt nicht so unbedingt
noch mehr leute rein haben nichts gegen
euch also das sollten also ist eine
person also ist jetzt auch so dass man
halt ins treibt also ich hab meine
arbeit für für privat also richtige
menschen die ich aus meinem leben kenne
und ich hatte wirklich auch ganz wenig
youtuber nur drin und auch nur welche
mit den wirklich viel zusammen machen
skype bei mir auch komplett privat ich
habe gerade mit einem will ja ich hab
ihm 17 kohle gegeben hat mehr als markt
gegeben was